il y à bien longtemps dans une galaxie
lointaine vivait un ordre de puissants
poète ces dix professeurs étaient
nombreux et respectés pour leur maîtrise
de la force du verbe repoussés par les
troupes magnifique d'un nouvel empire
ces résistants de l'imaginaire devenu
marginaux continuèrent pourtant de
lutter contre les illusions du pouvoir
et sa volonté de vaincre la mort aux
confins notre univers
quelques poètes rescapés continue de
prodiguer leurs enseignements pour
restaurer la paix dans la galaxie le
plus grand de ces guerriers philosophe
postule ainsi que la poésie sauvera le
monde aphorismes provocateur lancé assez
obscur détracteurs c'est à dire que
quand on a été touché profondément
soi-même sans aucun regard extérieur au
plus profond de ce conte et parle par un
vers d'un poème par une image par un
rythme quand on a été touché au plus
profond alors c'est comme du rapport
amoureux ça c'est un coup de foudre qui
n'a pas d'équivalent c'est ça qui
justifie qu'on lise du poème encore à 40
ans ou 60 ans quand on l'a jamais
éprouvé on n'y va pas il n'y a pas
besoin de diplôme et pas besoin de
savoir et pauvres
je sais pas de légitimité allez au poème
parce qu'à chaque fois vous entendrez
une langue 9
et qu'est-ce que nous et dont on a
besoin c'est ça de l'an neuf et qui
disent du qui disent l'imprévu de
nous-mêmes et du monde la part cachée la
part manquante celle dont on qui vit en
nous et qui n'a pas les mots le champ de
nos possibles et augmenter le champ de
la conscience de nous mêmes et augmenter
voilà pourquoi je dis que la ligue des
coudes d'apple nous grandit elle fait
grandir notre propre compte connaissance
de nous mêmes notre peau conscience de
nous mêmes et nous et de notre relation
à l'autre aux autres au monde à la vie
aux choses concrètes des c'est vrai de
kenneth white sevré d'andré velter c'est
vrai de tellement pas d'aujourd'hui qui
sont indisponibles
la disposition donc vous savez
il faut aller au hasard dans les
bibliothèques prendre des livres de
poèmes et lire la poésie d'aujourd'hui
échappant au pouvoir d'un empire il
n'est pas seul à résister et la
rébellion s'organise jour après jour
vers à prévert
hadj aïssa bell tv l'homme voilà c'est
jean françois manier ces le
fondateur des éditions cheyne lemaitre
peut être peut compter sur ses apprentis
qui parcourt la galaxie randonneurs
céleste armés de leurs textes outils de
la libertés jld et bois ma planète
j'ai des saints des escaliers marin
archives et de son vivant à la
bibliothèque du patrimoine de clermont
ferrand le maître s'assure du passage la
force créative du verbe pour poursuivre
la lutte
qu'est-ce que de sombres et qu'est ce
que devrait être ou pourrait être les
archives et ils vont évidemment il
faudrait pas que ce soit un tombereau
comme souvent le pensent beaucoup
bibliothèque essayer de le rendre vivant
ce fonds c'est à dire justement c'est
pas des archives morte mais derrière
vivante c'est à dire que ce qui est là
devrait donner en partage
peut-être en pâture je me trouve que
c'est bien pour que ce soit ouvert faut
que les gens m'aiment ça dédramatise ça
démystifie on se fait des idées de de
l'ouvroir de l'atelier secret du poète
août l'écrivain surtout le poète des
idées fausses il faut que des jeunes
parents des jeunes ils voient les
ratures ils voient les fautes
d'orthographes y voit les difficultés
des xes voit dans l'écriture de dans les
manuscrits la difficulté là le on
pourrait dire le labeur du dupe du poète
et ça c'est très bien qu'on demande des
archives des hôtes orient elles soient
disponibles pour qu'on que justement
papa que donc beaucoup équipe conditions
intervenu près de jeunes d'un milieu
scolaire donc on croit pas qu'il y ait
quelque chose de magique dans l'écriture
que c'est comme ça une sorte de deudon
céleste comme ça qui vous met en transe
et tournai où la parole de génial
advient sur la feuille
évidemment non et des biens qu'on voit
donc justement tout ce travail qu'on
appelle travail préparatoire où le moi
je dis qu'en tomberait à manu si on voit
de travail d'élaboration
le poète qu'il soit naïf utopiste ou
maudit et les demis de l'obscurité
sa sagesse est infini elle nous entoure
et nous pénètre contrairement aux
injonctions de lempire rapide facile et
séduisante forteresse de conformisme et
d'imposture cette obscurité se répand et
nous aliène
mais cette étoile noire sera vaincue par
la page blanche
la page manuscrite d'un écrivain c'est
peut-être le seul endroit où l'écriture
complètement libre parce que à ce moment
là en principe il est détaché de toute
obligation de tout regard extérieur
s'offre une sorte de regard qui ce
surmoi voilà mais autrement c'est un
essai un lieu où la langue se libère
complètement et les on n'a pas honte de
ce monde
d'une certaine façon de de sa nudité en
quelque sorte de deux savent franchise
de ses erreurs de et donc il ya quelque
chose de moi je trouve de très émouvant
quand je vois des manuscrits décrivent
un jeu très émouvant de voir la vérité
naître dans l'écriture